on a le plus grand papillon du monde qui
est venu tisania Agrippina il fait à peu
près 30 cm d'envergure ça raconte nous
c'est le restaurant des papillons en
quelque sorte bien sûr on a beaucoup de
fleurs pour que les papillons puissent
se nourrir mais c'est pas suffisant donc
on a deux types de plats on a les fruits
fermentés des bananes pour les grosses
espèces telles que les canigos les
papillons hiboux et puis à côté on a des
petites pailles on est censé imiter la
fleur alors je sais que pour nous ça
ressemble pas à une fleur mais le
papillon lui voit sa comme une fleur
parce qu'il y a des petits tubes jaunes
et on voit les trompes qui nous
enfoncent au plus profond du fruit c'est
pour ça qu'on la serre les fruits pour
qu'il puisse justement mettre leurs
trompes les papillons ne peuvent aspirer
que des liquides et papillons ne peuvent
manger que des liquides contrairement à
la chenille qui elle mastique les
feuilles mais le papillon lui n'a pas
d'autre possibilité que d'aspirer du
liquide
[Musique]
donc ça c'est pour montrer un des deux
canigos que nous élevons ici c'est le
plus beau caligo qui s'appelle la trius
et ce qui est particulier ici c'est que
comme tous les kaligots il y a un
faux-seuil ici qui en fait est destiné à
faire croire c'est un animal qui est
beaucoup plus gros qu'il n'est
réellement et cette partie là on
pourrait imaginer que c'est une tête de
serpent encore le papillon est en train
de manger en fait il se confond avec
autre chose et donc il est relativement
tranquille puisqu'il ressemble à autre
chose quand on l'ouvre par contre les
couleurs sont complètement différentes
voilà donc là il y a un magnifique
reflet bleu là aussi tous les Bleus dans
les papillons sont des couleurs
structurelles c'est à dire que ce sont
des écailles avec une forme prismatique
et qui attrape la lumière et quand il y
a beaucoup de lumière c'est très vif et
quand il y a pas de lumière c'est très
peu vif et donc ces couleurs là lui
servent à quoi alors ça c'est bon ça
c'est un mal je pense que ces couleurs
sont assez vives parce que donc ça
permet d'impressionner la femelle qui va
le draguer
alors là aussi il y a une chose qui est
très intéressante ce sont ces fleurs
jaunes oranges c'est la plante idéale
pour les élus connus c'est la famille
des concombres et cette plante donne non
seulement du nectar au papillon mais
elle leur procure du pollen et en fait
le pollen leur permet d'être plus fécond
et de vivre des mois au lieu de vivre
quelques semaines
là on récupère les œufs dans des petits
gobelets en plastique donc on sépare
bien sûr chaque espèce comme tu peux
voir il y a des œufs qui sont plus gros
que d'autres les œufs maintenant vont
être traités on va les désinfecter les
passer à la lumière ultraviolette pour
s'assurer que d'éventuelles bactéries ou
virus qui soit transmise par les parents
soit en fait inactifs
sur chacune d'élevage on a une petite
fiche d'identité avec la date du début
de l'élevage le long de l'espèce et la
quantité de chenilles qu'on a placé donc
déjà les chenilles sont ont eu le temps
de grandir un petit peu elle faisait que
quelques millimètres quand elles sont
nées donc là elles ont déjà pas mal
grandi faut savoir qu'une chenille mue
plusieurs fois dans sa vie parce qu'en
fait c'est comme un enfant qui grandit
les vêtements deviennent trop petits
donc là en l'occurrence c'est la peau et
la chenille doit changer entre 4 et 5
fois pour une peau un peu plus souple
ça c'est l'une des chenilles les plus
urticantes qui existent c'est une
chenille de papillon de nuit qui est
parée de multiples épines et toi tu les
mets sur ton doigt tranquille en la
prenant comme ça elle ne me pique pas
mais par contre si j'ai fleur ne
serait-ce que les épines elles ont une
sorte de venin dans les épines et donc
ça provoque une brûlure c'est en fait
une défense qu'à la chenille parce
qu'elle n'est pas elle n'est pas
agressive en soi mais elle se défend
comme elle peut
[Musique]
donc là elles sont arrivés au bout
pratiquement de leur croissance et elle
commence à se chrysalider et elles vont
se criser l'idée dans les cocons
au milieu des feuilles à l'intérieur de
ce mélange de soie et de feuilles se
trouve une chenille qui est en train de
se créer à l'idée on peut rappeler aussi
à cette occasion que le cocon le
concerne que les papillons de nuit c'est
une enveloppe de soi et de mélange de
feuilles qui sert à protéger la
chrysalide les papillons de jour ne font
jamais de cocon
[Musique]
là ça permet d'illustrer la fameuse
chrysalide dorée c'est magnifique on
tient un bijou voilà qui est l'or le
plus éphémère du monde puisqu'il dure 9
jours le temps de la de la
chrysalisation on part d'une chenille
qui est noir et blanche ensuite une
chrysalide qui est jaune pour devenir
dorée pour devenir un papillon qui est
noir orange et jaune elle change
complètement de couleur tout au long de
sa vie tout à fait incroyable
[Musique]
pour que cette exploitation fonctionne
Mathieu donc tu vends des chrysalides à
dessert un peu partout dans le monde ce
que tu peux nous expliquer comment ça se
passe et bien écoute voilà une fois par
semaine on expédie des chrysalides soit
aux États-Unis soit en Europe on expédie
à peu près 1500 chrysalides par semaine
et donc c'est toute petite boîte qui
partent voilà alors on utilise ces
boîtes de polystyrène qui ont l'avantage
de d'éviter les chocs thermiques dans
une petite boîte comme ça on met 400
chrysalides 400 CHR là il y a une
première couche de coton ce qu'on va
faire c'est que je vais commencer à
disposer les chrysalides évidemment dès
que la chrysalide va être réceptionnée
donc dans quelques jours il va falloir
la placer immédiatement dans un éclosoir
avec des conditions de température et
d'hygrométrie qui elles doivent être
vraiment très très contrôlées et parmi
les serres qui sont tes clients il y
aura dans quelques mois Tropicalia tout
à fait et en plus l'avantage avec
Tropicalia c'est que contrairement à
beaucoup de serres qui sont fermés
l'hiver ça va permettre d'expédier des
papillons toute l'année et pour nous
c'est très important d'avoir des
personnes qui puissent nous commander
des papillons toute l'année
[Musique]
bon alors Mathieu tu nous as fait lever
à 5h du matin il y a une violente
lumière qui nous éclaire le visage
explique-nous un peu mais écoute on a
placé cette lumière spéciale pour
attirer les papillons de nuit et
effectivement on n'est pas des sucres on
a les classiques Sphinx donc les
papillons quand ils sont au repos ils
ont l'aile en forme de triangle la
partie la plus colorée de l'aile se
trouve dans l'aile inférieure et elle
est cachée par l'autre
là il s'agit de rothschilda le beau il y
a une partie transparente dans l'aile
ils ont les fenêtres c'est un genre de
papillon qui sont parmi des plus beaux
en nocturne d'Amérique du Sud ils ont la
particularité d'avoir une partie de
l'aile sans écaille d'accord et il y a
combien d'espèces de papillons nocturnes
dans le monde alors il y a 10 fois plus
de papillons de nuit que de jour donc
s'il y a 15000 papillons de jour on
estime qu'il y a 150 000 papillons de
nuit dans le monde dont un certain
nombre qui n'ont pas encore été
découvert et en Équateur tu dirais qu'il
y en a combien entre 15 et 20 000
on a le plus grand papillon du monde qui
est venu tisania Agrippina il fait à peu
près 30 cm d'envergure c'est cette
énorme papillon blanc
[Musique]
ça y est je l'ai